[Música]
ese soy yo si super feliz en una de mis
épocas favoritas si en el país más feliz
del mundo
claro mismo país que hace unos meses a
finales del año pasado se identificó que
el 61 por ciento de nuestros
costarricenses presentaba sintomatología
de depresión
61%
y es que si yo preguntara que quien es
de nosotros se ha matriculado alguna vez
en un gimnasio o en un centro de
acondicionamiento físico posiblemente la
mayoría diría que todos que sí
pero y la salud mental
que hemos hecho por la salud mental
hace algún tiempo yo decidí no tener un
cuerpo fit aunque todos quisiéramos sino
tener el alma y la mente fit y cuando
hablamos de alma y mente inmediatamente
hablamos de salud mental y hablar de
salud mental es hablar de cosas
oscuras prejuicios prejuicios miedos
si hasta hace algún tiempo la
esquizofrenia era un asunto de posesión
demoníaca
y yo les comento una la primera vez que
tuve un ataque de pánico lo primero que
hice estaba sola lo primero que hice fue
decir qué vergüenza tuve un ataque de
pánico
yo
esmeralda enfermera en salud mental me
juzgue a mí mismo por tener un ataque de
pánico
y no es de esperarse eso pasa con la
salud mental pero la realidad es que
todos tenemos nuestras maletas en el
tema de salud mental desde la niñez
echamos cosas en estas maletas en la
niñez en la adolescencia en la adultez
está llena de traumas tal vez de dolores
o de experiencias agradables sí pero
esas maletas pesan y hay que estar
jalando
hay que ejercitar nuestra mente para
poder abrir a veces esas maletas y ver
que hay
ver que podemos sacar que otras cosas
podemos limpiar tal vez hay algo sucio
también podemos revisar qué cosas ya no
es necesario cargar y dejar pero eso
solo ejercitando la mente y así como ir
al gimnasio trabajar nuestra salud
mental es muy es desafiante sí a veces
no queremos ir al gimnasio está
lloviendo hace frío pan pancito dulce
con café igual pasa con la salud mental
pero cuando ya estamos en el gimnasio
retomamos todo hay una gran maleta que
estamos cargando todos y es la maleta de
la pandemia y quien diga que esto no le
ha afectado
posiblemente sea una persona no tan
honesta pero a todos nos ha afectado y
la salud mental en general es un tema
pesado y pesado duro la o&m se estima
que cerca de 300 mil personas al año
fallecen por causa de suicidio
300.000 y podríamos decir bueno 300.000
en el mundo cuántos millones de personas
hay
sí pero esos 300 mil son la familia de
alguien mamá de alguien hermano amigo
pareja de alguien
y es que si hablamos de enfermedad
física cuando nos diagnostica un
padecimiento que nos dicen
ok va a seguir este plan nutricional
va a seguir estos ejercicios físicos
también va a tomar su medicación y por
supuesto que va a tener unas citas
control pero qué pasa cuando tenemos un
padecimiento de salud mental que nos
dicen siéntase bien sea positivo
y la realidad es que ser positivo y
sentirse bien no siempre es suficiente
salud mental abarca desde un trastorno
de personalidad hasta un no puedo dormir
de tanto pensar pero nos encanta
categorizar nos encanta decir esto es
importante y esto no tanto
hace algún tiempo tuve una crisis le
escribí a mi psicóloga y le dije podemos
adelantar mi cita
me dijo muy bien te ofrezco estas fechas
pero si es una emergencia puede ser
mañana a tal hora te abro un espacio que
no estaba yo no es una emergencia porque
claro como no vemos una pierna sangrando
y fracturada no es una emergencia porque
la salud mental no se ve tan fácilmente
claro después dije no si es una
emergencia era una emergencia para mí y
ese es el punto no podemos desestimar lo
que siente la otra persona y mucho menos
desestimar lo que siento yo es por eso
que hoy aquí les traigo una propuesta
para revolucionar la salud mental y es
la creación de gimnasios más mente y
alma fit
existen los gimnasios mentales y en
algunos lugares nacen en eeuu y en
europa en españa principalmente pero
esto lo que hace es trabajar procesos
cognitivos si trastornos del
neurodesarrollo
pero y qué pasa con esa persona que
todas las noches tiene problemas con
manejar esa ansiedad para enfrentar el
día a día y qué pasa con esa persona que
es manager en una empresa pero se le
dificulta gestionar sus emociones porque
nunca tuvo las herramientas para poderlo
hacer porque es algo que no aprendemos
en la escuela y en el colegio
qué pasa con ellos eso también es salud
mental
y no digo que haya que tengamos que
dejar de ir al gimnasio no es un
compuesto somos seres holístico se
indivisibles y necesitamos de las dos
cosas pero me imagino llegando a un
gimnasio map donde nos recibe el coach
nos hace una evaluación
nos pregunta cómo has estado que estás
comiendo noticias relaciones abusivas
redes sociales cuáles son tus objetivos
porque los objetivos de todos en el
gimnasio son diferentes
nos hace toda esa evaluación con una
evaluación física también por parte de
la enfermera física y mental para
determinar qué es lo mejor porque claro
lo físico es importantísimo hay varios
estudios que han demostrado en personas
con diabetes que posterior a una
intervención en salud mental disminuyen
los los niveles de glucosa en sangre
somos un top no podemos separarnos
entonces yo visualizo un plan que tal
vez tenga por ejemplo una sesión semanal
con una sesión al mes de psicoterapia
con la psicóloga del gimnasio más
también 30 minutos en la sala de
silencio si fuese la versión presencial
porque habrá una versión virtual también
el silencio se ha demostrado en una
serie de investigaciones llamadas la
revolución del silencio que tiene un
impacto a nivel de la educación
contemplativa en la neurociencia y
también a nivel espiritual que aunque no
tengamos ninguna religión la
espiritualidad es parte de todos
también este plan podría incluir el
ejercicio de respiración consciente
se ha demostrado en la universidad de
tennessee en en el área de neurobiología
que la respiración consciente permite la
claridad de pensamiento e impacta todos
muchos procesos cognitivos superiores
como la atención la memoria y la
representación espacial
yo visualizo y no solo esto también
podrían elegir un montón de clases
libres por ejemplo relaciones
interpersonales felicidad empresarial
danza danza terapia arte terapia
y una serie de cosas grupos de apoyo por
ejemplo grupos de apoyo de personas con
diabetes no solo para trabajar su salud
mental sino que también trabajaríamos
adherencia al tratamiento por ejemplo
sería algo sumamente complejo yo
visualizo
empresas con gimnasio es más donde la
producción aumenta la productividad
disminuyen las incapacidades según la
onpe o ps en el 2019
sigue siendo la principal causa de
incapacidad y las afectaciones de la
salud mental
y hay un estudio sobre felicidad
empresarial en méxico y se determinó que
cuando los empleados están felices se
disminuye un 300% los accidentes
laborales entonces estamos hablando de
que un gimnasio más sería sumamente
rentable para una empresa y lo visualizo
en centros de estudio de aprendizaje
universidades colegios
escuelas se imaginan a los niños
aprendiendo sobre gestión emocional
consentimiento límites ponerlos y
respetarlos seríamos revolucionando el
mundo
en general en la comunidad en todas
partes ahora yo les traigo esta
propuesta y la idea no es que digan hay
que que lindo me encanta
la idea es que tomemos acción
61% de personas con síntomas de
depresión en nuestro país nuestra
familia nuestros vecinos nuestros amigos
qué vas a hacer vos para cambiar eso qué
vas a hacer vos
para cambiar eso en tu trabajo en tu
comunidad en tu casa qué vas a hacer vos
para tener el alma y la mente fib
[Música]